bonjour est ce m kurtovitch merci d'être
avec nous ce matin sur rtl france alors
tout d'abord que faut-il penser de cette
érosion en quoi est-ce historique pour
la nouvelle calédonie il ya c'est
historique parce que comme vous l'avez
dit c'est la première fois depuis
l'accord de nouméa qu'un
indépendantistes kanaks président le
gouvernement jusqu'à présent les
indépendantistes et exercer la fonction
de vice président du gouvernement et
occupé jusqu'à 5 siège du gouvernement
mais cette fois ci il y à deux
changements importants
c'est un homme dépendant disques et les
présidents et les pouvoirs du président
sont importants et ensuite il a une
majorité avec lui de six membres sur 11
du gouvernement qui sont également
indépendantiste donc en cela c'est tout
à fait nouveau jusqu'à présent c'était
le contraire
il y avait six membres du gouvernement
non indépendantiste et 4 ou 5
indépendantiste le gouvernement de la
nouvelle calédonie et collégial c'est à
dire indépendantistes et non
indépendantiste y participent
vous parliez tout à l'heure des pouvoirs
importants du président est ce que
justement où il m'a pouva pouvoir peser
sur sur la politique de la nouvelle
calédonie dans dans l'émoi dans les
années à venir
oui le gouvernement de la nouvelle
calédonie alors c'est particulier parce
que notre pays est divisé en province
qui ont qui ont de très importantes
compétences qui ont la compétence de
droit est aussi un gouvernement qui a
une compétence générale dans certains
domaines donc en fait c'est à pouvoir
partager dans le cadre de ce pouvoir
partager le président exerce une vraie
responsabilité le dans le cadre de ses
compétences et aussi le gouvernement est
en collégiale c'est très particulier
toutes les décisions de chats membres
requis hier la
signature et donc l'accord du président
ce qui fait que le président comme l'a
dit monsieur ma peau qui est un homme
politique de grande expérience et dans
la foi
le président de sa majorité et il a il
est aussi le président de tout son
gouvernement
donc il doit à la fois imprimé son
propre programme et en même temps
conduire collégialement les affaires du
pays pour ce qui les concerne
alors on le disait tout à l'heure
nouveau référendum en fin d'année sur
l'indépendance de la nouvelle calédonie
troisième référendum
c'est ce que justement cette élection de
2000 un coup peut représenter un espoir
pour les indépendantistes qu'elle et
devient eh bien oui c'est un cran
supplémentaire parce que en nouvelle
calédonie les indépendantistes
participons aux responsabilités à tous
les étages et à tous les gestions de
chaque état là sauf à celui du
gouvernement et là c'est une première
commande comme on vient de le dire mais
effectivement le fait d'assumer la
présidence du gouvernement donne un rôle
nouveau aux indépendantistes dans le cas
de cette institution
sauf que la procédure d'accession à
l'indépendance de la nouvelle calédonie
est parallèle à la gestion des affaires
du pays et en somme même si le
personnage du deux présidents deux
gouvernements a un rôle trop parce que
le protocole mis au point
prévoir un référendum et récemment sous
l'égide de monsieur le bord nu le corps
nu le ministre de l'outre-mer un accord
de transition a été conclu pour que à
l'issue du référendum une période soit
consacrée aux négociations entre partis
politiques
donc il y a plusieurs parties prenantes
mais c'est sûr que le président du
gouvernement
ce sera au tour de la table en tant que
tel alors très rapidement avant de se
quitter semaine kurtovitch on le disait
un troisième référendum à la fin de
l'année sur l'indépendance de la
nouvelle calédonie les deux premiers
s'étaient soldées par une victoire du
non est ce que cette fois le oui est
vraiment envisageable
oui tout le
le référendum les deux composantes
politiques peuvent peuvent le gagner
c'est un référendum équitable
ce troisième des notables parce que
l'état a produit un document qu'il n'a
ce qu'il n'avait pas fait pour les deux
premiers donnons les conséquences du oui
pour l'état c'est à dire que la france
considèrera que si la réponse est oui
la nouvelle calédonie deviendra un pays
en somme un pays étranger et sera traité
comme tel au besoin dans le cadre
d'accords de coopération mais comme un
pays étranger donc ça c'est l'élément
nouveau qui est plus présent dans la
campagne électorale en raison des
discussions qui ont lieu à paris et des
les éléments de décision à ce sujet car
apporter l'état merci beaucoup il se met
kurtovitch d'avoir été avec nous
aujourd'hui sur arte france rappelle que
vous êtes historien et spécialiste de la
nouvelle calédonie contemporaine merci
beaucoup